est ce que le nouveau ministre de la
jutice vue de la justice pardon vous a
convaincu dans sa mission de redresser
le service public de la justice monsieur
dupont moretti porte sur la justice le
regard du justiciable
il fait des diagnostics que nous pouvons
partager sur la situation
pénurie des moyens des tribunaux de
l'immobilier de la justice de
l'informatique de la justice sur le
manque de greffiers sur la complexité
qui exige de la simplification
l'éloignement qui exige plus de
proximité
nous attendons maintenant de lui plus
que ces diagnostics
nous attendons des réponses et c'est sa
responsabilité de ministre dont il est
en train de prendre toute la mesure
c'est un homme sincère et je crois
conscients de l'importance de ses
responsabilités il a rappelé qu'il avait
600 jours pour agir
nous attendons lui maintenant que ils
obtiennent l'accroissement des moyens du
service public de la justice
il n'a pas été en mesure d'annoncer
d'arbitrage à ce jour eh bien nous
attendons avec impatience ses arbitrages
nous pensions qu'il avait déjà obtenu
des garanties du premier ministre et du
président de la république nous a
simplement dit qu'il allait reprendre la
trajectoire entre guillemets interrompu
de la loi de programmation pour la
justice car non seulement la loi de
programmation des moyens pour la justice
n'est pas à la hauteur mais en plus elle
n'est pas appliquée nous voulons non
seulement qu'elle soit impliquée mais
aussi que les moyens des tribunaux
soient augmentés et en contrepartie que
les méthodes de la justice soit
modernisée notamment sur le plan
informatique et sur le plan de la
simplification des procédures et de
rapprochement des justiciables et
surtout ses chapitres des pistes sont
ouvertes mais les réponses se font
encore attendre
ça n'est pas pour l'instant un motif
préoccupation il faut laisser au
ministre le temps de prendre en main ces
dossiers mais il est évident que dans
les prochaines semaines les réponses
devront être apportées est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va mener à terme cette
réforme pour plus d'indépendance du
parquet il al'air volontariste sur cette
question mais la question est
aujourd'hui entièrement du côté du
président de la république puisque
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat ont
voté il ya plusieurs années déjà une
révision de la constitution sur la
nomination des procureurs
cette révision n'est pas l'urgence de la
justice l'urgence de la justice c'est le
service public qu'il fonctionne bien à
la satisfaction des français mais il y à
une réforme qui est en cours et la
procédure constitutionnelle
c'est soit le référendum soit la réunion
du congrès le ministre a paru annoncé
tout à l'heure qui est le président
allait réunir le congrès et puis à la
fin de l'audition il s'est ravisé et
bien attendons la décision du président
de la république
attendons de voir la décision d'
emmanuel macron alors autre question qui
concerne l'état d'urgence sanitaire le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité a été beaucoup critiquée par
les sénateurs sur le manque de contrôle
virologique dans les aéroports et le
ministre de la santé a répété à
plusieurs reprises que c'était le sénat
qui l'avait désarmé au niveau législatif
pour contraindre les ressortir les
ressortissants de l'étranger des pays à
risque à faire ces contrôles qu'est ce
que vous lui répondait j'ai envie de
vous dire que de mon point de vue le
rôle d'un ministre est d'être impartial
et pas de lancer des polémiques la loi
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
a été votée par les deux chambres en
accord avec le gouvernement et si elle
n'est pas bonne
monsieur verrons peut d'abord s'en
prendre à lui même mais je considère que
cette loi offre tous les moyens
nécessaires
elle prévoit le test de dépistage avant
l'embarquement pour la france la
vérification que ce texte est négatif et
dans l'hypothèse où il y aurait des
personnes contaminées
la mise en quarantaine enfin une
quarantaine qui dure en réalité
jours et la loi donne au gouvernement
évidemment tous les moyens d'agir
il serait vain de se défausser sur le
parlement des responsabilités qui
incombent à l'exécutif
je crois que il ya eu sans doute un
excès d'emportement de la part d'un
ministre qui a pris ses fonctions il ya
quelques mois et qui doit raison garder
et garder son objectivité aussi merci
beaucoup au feeling